we're going to begin with protests that
erupted in minnesota last night over a
man's death
after a traffic stop just 10 miles from
the site of the derrick chauvin trial
police used tear gas and flash bangs in
some places to disperse the crowd
the family of dante wright say police
shot and killed him yesterday afternoon
and police are saying that they learned
of an outstanding warrant against wright
after they pulled him over
jamie yukis is at the brooklyn center
minnesota police department where the
crowds gathered last night jamie good
morning
to you what's it like there this morning
well tony i want to show you what my
crew found as they were setting up this
is a non-lethal mark around and you can
see this big
piece of non-lethal ammunition is shot
at crowds to quickly get them to
disperse and while
there aren't any people still here
police are still on high alert
after officers clashed with protesters
here outside the station
the national guard is still here this
morning as well to help control any
threats
the mayor also issued a curfew order
early this morning
this adds to the already high tensions
in the minneapolis area
as derek chovan's murder trial continues
today
marching through the city protesters met
a line of officers at the brooklyn
center police department
who used flash bangs and tear gas to try
to break up the group
we saw a rocks and other objects
thrown at the police department there
were reports of shots fired in the area
of the police department
earlier in the day dozens gathered in
the same spot
where family says dante wright was
killed by police
[Applause]
his mother katie wright says dante
called her right before the incident
that he was getting pulled over by the
police and i said well why
did you get pulled over he said he had
they pulled him over because he had air
fresheners hanging from the rear mirror
he didn't deserve to be shot and killed
like this
the 20-year-old allegedly drove away
when police say officers tried to arrest
him on an
outstanding warrant one officer fired a
shot at the car and hit wright
who allegedly continued driving several
blocks before hitting another car
wright died at the scene and no one else
was seriously injured
police are investigating and say dash
and body cameras appear to have been
activated at the time
the shooting took place just 15 miles
from where george floyd was killed by
minneapolis police last may
as the murder trial of derrick chauvin
continues today
residents say this adds to the hurt pain
and grief i mean
trauma we're already in a trial with
george floyd
we're at a breaking point as a people
today in the trial we expect the
prosecution to wrap up
at least one of george floyd's family
members is likely to testify
the case then moves to the defense where
everyone will be watching to see
if derek chovin testifies on his own
behalf gail
that is the question especially after
the last two weeks of testimony thank
you very much jamie